[Música]
tercer día de los ataques de rusia
contra ucrania los militares enviados
por moscú están cada vez más cerca de
kiev la capital mientras que occidente
endurecen las sanciones contra los
bancos rusos
por otra parte en diferentes partes del
mundo salieron cientos de manifestantes
a rechazar la ofensiva militar rusa hubo
desde llamados de paz hasta insultos al
presidente ruso vladimir putin
y una de las ofensivas que ha habido en
ucrania es que las fuerzas rusas ya se
tomaron a la ciudad de chernóbil en esta
visión analizaremos cuál es el riesgo
nuclear de que esto haya ocurrido y qué
significa en el panorama militar
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy [__] la calle y es un placer
saludarlos y comenzamos esta emisión en
la capital ucraniana porque las fuerzas
rusas aprietan su cerco desde esta
mañana las calles del centro están
vacías hay combates en las afueras y se
escuchan detonaciones el ejército ruso
ordenó ampliar su ofensiva en ucrania
desde todas las direcciones y de acuerdo
con inteligencia británica el grueso de
las tropas rusas está a 30 kilómetros
del centro de kiev
este edificio residencial acaba de ser
alcanzado por un misil
[Música]
su fachada está devastada
conseguimos escapar tuvimos suerte
porque estábamos en la cocina cuando la
primera bomba impactó en la entrada mi
esposa y mi hijo mayor tenían las
piernas rotas mi hijo menor fue llevado
a algún lugar por el equipo de rescate
no estoy buscando en varias partes de la
capital se han presentado disparos de
misiles y combates todavía no hay tropas
regulares rusas pero el ejército
ucraniano dice haber repelido un ataque
a una de las principales arterias de la
ciudad
el presidente ucraniano hizo un nuevo
llamado a la movilización
voy a trabajar estamos resistiendo con
éxito pero los enfrentamientos continúan
en todo el país estamos luchando para
proteger nuestra tierra y el futuro de
nuestros hijos mantenemos el control de
kiev y de puntos estratégicos alrededor
de la ciudad mientras los atacantes
intentan apoderarse de nuestro país
ahora los rusos están concentrando sus
ataques en kiev al norte del país y en
harkov más al este pero también han
golpeado otras ciudades en kiev tras el
asalto nocturno de las fuerzas rusas los
residentes se preparan para lo peor
desde esta mañana este hombre está
cavando una trinchera en medio de una
carretera en la capital las calles están
desiertas mientras familias enteras se
refugian en los sótanos de los edificios
residenciales para los que han decidido
marcharse el éxodo continúa decenas de
miles de personas ya han sido
desplazadas quien se encuentra bajo un
toque de queda hasta el próximo lunes a
medida que las tropas rusas se acercan
el gobierno local emitió un anuncio
diciendo que todo aquel que viole la
medida será considerado como enemigo
previamente desde la capital ucraniana
nuestra corresponsal y gran sabio nos
explicó en qué consiste el toque de
queda impuestos
si el toque de queda que se ha impuesto
en esta tercera noche de guerra con
rusia consiste en que toda la población
y también los medios de comunicación no
pueden salir a la calle hasta las 8 de
la mañana de este lunes este toque de
queda
implica que las personas
que no cumplan con esta disposición
pueden ser considerados enemigos y por
tanto también exponerse a hacer tiros
grados en el gobierno de que sea
justificado por esta disposición
diciendo que esta es la manera en que
piensan a frenar la entrada de
saboteadores espías rusos que estarían
circulando por la ciudad y hace tan sólo
unos minutos hemos podido nuevamente
escuchar las sirenas y nuevos también
estallidos nuestra corresponsal también
nos contó que podría pasar esta noche en
kiev
pues la verdad es que nos esperamos una
noche muy larga y de nuevo de poco
dormir
después de que el ministerio de defensa
ruso dijera que planea intensificar la
presión bélica sobre la ciudad de kiev
después de estos primeros días de
combates en toda la ciudad lo que se
espera en esta noche es un aumento de
los bombardeos de los enfrentamientos
callejeros y por supuesto como también
decíamos antes un aumento de las bajas
no sólo militares sino también de
civiles pero habrá que realmente que
esperar para conocer exactamente lo que
ocurrirá esta noche y mientras en
ucrania avanza el despliegue de tropas
rusas en diferentes partes del mundo hay
protestas para rechazar los ataques de
moscú el icónico time square en nueva
york se vistió con banderas de ucrania
la mayoría de manifestantes son
ucranianos y georgia nos estos últimos
afirmaron que kiev los respaldó en 2008
cuando rusia se enfrente a georgia por
osetia del sur
de paraguay las manifestaciones fueron
en la ciudad de encarnación los
asistentes afirmaron que el país
suramericano tiene una importante
comunidad de inmigrantes ucranianos
desde allí y pidieron la paz en europa
del este y rechazaron los operativos
ordenados por vladimir putin no queremos
guerra es el grito que se escuchó en
parís también hubo pancartas para
rechazar a putin y decirle que recojan
los cadáveres que ha dejado en suelo
ucraniano desde la capital francesa
pidieron que cesara el conflicto
en rumanía los manifestantes se pintaron
las manos de rojo y las plasmaron en el
edificio de la embajada rusa y además
exhibieron una bandera ucraniana en las
calles de bucarest varios de los
asistentes nacieron en ucrania y
contaron que algunos de sus amigos en su
país de origen están escondidos en
búnkers
hace dos días rusia se tomó la ciudad
ucraniana de chernóbil conocida por la
explosión de una planta nuclear en
1986 además esto es un lugar estratégico
porque queda tan solo 17 km de belarús
que es un país aliado de rusia y desde
donde han partido tropas del kremlin
también es una de las ciudades más
cercanas aquí es la capital ucraniana
pues está a 70 km para entender la
importancia de chernóbil vamos a esta
hora hasta buenos aires donde estaba
julián gadano él es director del
programa de estudios de energía nuclear
e innovación de la universidad nacional
de tres de febrero en argentina
bienvenido señor gadano a france24 el
asesor presidencial ucraniano calificó
la toma de chernóbil como una de las
amenazas más graves en la europa en
europa en la actualidad y el organismo
internacional de energía atómica pidió
no poner en riesgo las centrales
entonces cuál es el peligro nuclear de
que los rusos se hayan tomado esta
ciudad
y en realidad por supuesto el tema
nuclear es complicado porque rusia es
una potencia nuclear yo creo que en el
tema más simbólico que otra cosa en
realidad la central de chernóbil está
protegida una central de origen
soviético con lo cual ruso de sobre el
auto simbolismo pero digamos la central
de chernóbil está protegida por un por
algo que técnicamente llamamos sarcófago
que es un edificio digamos que blinda lo
que hay adentro de la central de
chernóbil y yo creo que el objetivo de
rusia no está en la central sino lo que
llaman la zona de exclusión que es una
zona de 30 kilómetros a la redonda la
central donde está incluida por ejemplo
la ciudad dónde vivían antes los
operadores eta que se llama propia y que
es una zona que les permite a los rusos
penetrar fácilmente
a ucrania desde bielorrusia como tú
dijiste está a menos de 20 kilómetros de
bielorrusia y a su vez está
relativamente cerca de que lleva 30
kilos a 100 perdón kilómetros de kiel
con lo cual en realidad el objetivo de
chernóbil es menos nuclear que logístico
para facilitarles del norte de
bielorrusia la invasión
a la capital aquí pero entonces en este
sentido de lo que usted nos habla se
puede decir que la capacidad de
chernóbil de producir energía nuclear no
es tan determinante en la avanzada
militar rusa no definitivamente no
porque de hecho el cannabis no genera
energía nuclear ya desde hace décadas
está cerrada y está cubierta el reactor
4 que fue el que tuvo el accidente en
1986 cubierta por este sarcófago lo que
sí es importante tener en cuenta es que
ucrania tiene otras centrales nucleares
en operación tiene cuatro centrales
alrededor de su territorio no cerca de
esa zona pero alrededor su territorio
con 15 reactores y eso sí está en
operación están activos y digamos
esperaríamos que dentro de la guerra se
tomaran las prácticas dentro de la
tragedia de la invasión se tomarán las
precauciones de no afectar los reactores
que por ahora están lejos de la zona de
conflicto y esos 15 reactores de los que
usted nos habla que tan relevante es en
la producción de energía nuclear en todo
el mundo
en todo el mundo
digamos quizás depende mucho cada país
es muy relevante para ucrania ucrania es
un país que depende mucho la energía
nuclear y por lo tanto digamos depende
de que esos reactores operen para tener
energía en google es un país con digamos
es importante están dentro de los
digamos primeros lugares realista en
cuanto a la proporción de energía
nuclear dentro de su matriz eléctrica el
país que tiene más en el que no que
dentro de su matriz eléctrica
precisamente francia que también digamos
debajo tras eeuu procrear es un país con
con una importancia importante
proporción de energía nuclear dentro de
su matriz julián gadano gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 y por
todo este panorama entonces ahora
nosotros vamos a que rusia anunció el
cierre de su espacio aéreo a los aviones
vinculados con bulgaria polonia y
república checa en otra parte de la
aerolínea de letonia dijo que cancelaba
todos los vuelos a rusia hasta el 26 de
marzo debido al aumento de riesgos
mientras que alemania se roció espacio
aéreo para los aviones rusos el aro de
este país lufthansa canceló todos los
vuelos de la próxima semana que iban
hacia rusia lo mismo hizo la compañía
neerlandesa kl
y grupos de ucranianos siguen haciendo
su camino de huida del país a medida que
avanza la invasión unos 150.000
refugiados se dirigieron hacia polonia
rumanía y otros países vecinos el bloque
europeo dijo que está listo para acoger
a quienes buscan un lugar seguro la
mayoría son mujeres y niños después el
gobierno activó a los hombres entre 18 y
60 años para proteger al país a veces
desechó obviamente la situación es
extremadamente fluida vemos los números
y la situación cambiar minuto a minuto
rain agua pero en este momento lo que
podemos confirmar es que al menos
150.000 personas han huido a flat de
ahora son refugiados fuera de ucrania
you can we now that turista sabemos que
al menos 100.000 pero probablemente un
número mucho mayor ya se han desplazado
internamente dentro de ucrania you came
oxidante se une para sancionar a rusia
la presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen anunció que hay un
consenso para remover a ciertos bancos
rusos del sistema swift lo que los
desconectaría del campo internacional
financiero ella también afirmó que
querían
las acciones del banco central de rusia
y que trabajarán para evitar que los
oligarcas rusos usen su dinero en el
mercado internacional
esto lo apoyan eeuu francia alemania
italia canadá y reino unido- según von
der leyen todo es con el fin de parar la
financiación de la máquina de guerra de
rusia como la llama
a sólo una docena de kilómetros de la
frontera oriental de la unión europea el
ejército ruso está cometiendo acciones
bárbaras durante su invasión de ucrania
está bombardeando y lanzando misiles
matando a personas inocentes
entonces
mientras las fuerzas rusas liberan su
asalto a kiev y otras ciudades
ucranianas estamos decididos a seguir
imponiendo costes masivos a rusia costes
que aislarán aún más a rusia del sistema
financiero internacional y de nuestras
economías
y el propósito del nuevo anuncio de las
sanciones estas no son las primeras la
unión europea de reino unido y eeuu ya
habían reaccionado para castigar a rusia
en este informe les explicamos y las
sanciones tiene algún impacto sobre los
individuos o si sólo afectarán al estado
golpearles donde les duele las sanciones
contra rusia continúan llegando primero
contra vladimir putin la unión europea y
reino unido- congelaron todos los
activos del responsable del kremlin
estimados en miles de millones de euros
las sanciones más extremas afectarán
sobre todo al estado ruso por encima de
cualquier individuo las represalias
también tendrán efectos sobre el sector
comercial ya que se dejará de vender
tecnología a rusia lo mismo ocurre con
los nuevos aviones y equipos
aeronáuticos en eeuu los bancos deberán
cortar sus vínculos de corresponsalía
bancaria con el mayor prestamista ruso
sberbank en un plazo de 30 días pero
será todo esto suficiente presión que se
nota las sanciones occidentales no
tendrán un impacto tan importante la
economía rusa en todo caso mucho menos
de lo previsto porque rusia ya las había
anticipado desde hace varios años
si entendió que pasara lo que pasara
debía proteger su sector financiero de
la probable introducción de nuevas
sanciones en los próximos años
putin lleva mucho tiempo preparándose
para esta coyuntura en los últimos
cuatro años las reservas de oro y de
divisas del país aumentaron
considerablemente de 448.000 millones de
dólares en 2018 a más de 630 mil
millones de dólares en la actualidad la
invasión ha hecho temer una escasez de
suministros a nivel mundial europa por
su parte tiene una última arma negar
potencialmente el acceso de los bancos
rusos a swift un sistema de manejo de
transacciones seguro que conecta a más
de 11.000 instituciones financieras en
más de 200 países y territorios
algunas naciones como francia quieren
cortar el acceso de rusia inmediatamente
pero otros países más dependientes del
gas ruso como alemania son más reacios
por temor a represalias
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que consulten más información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom donde
tendremos todo actualizado al minuto
[Música]